nous sommes avec sophie crozier
neurologue à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris
membre du comité consultatif national
d'éthique et membre du collectif inter
hôpitaux bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
d'abord votre réaction à cette journée
d'action nationale
hier avec des manifestations émaillées
de heurts dans la capitale
bah écoute et merci à vous bonjour nous
ce que je construis retient surtout
cette journée de manifestations et de
mobilisation hier c'est que ça a été une
immense mobilisation sur l'ensemble du
territoire français je pense que c'est
vraiment ça ce qu'on va retenir
principalement évidemment grande
mobilisation de la part des soignants
mais aussi des citoyens qui étaient
extrêmement nombreux dans le dans toutes
les manifestations donc ça a été un
quelque chose de très important avec
effectivement une plutôt dans la
majorité des de la majorité des endroits
la quasi totalité d'ailleurs une très
bonne une très bonne ambiance et une
vraie détermination par contre de la
part des soignants pour être entendu
maintenant par le gouvernement c'est
important d'être entendu il reste très
peu de temps avant que le gouvernement
ne donne ses réponses dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé ce sera au mois de
juillet donc il faut c'est important de
mettre la pression sur son gouvernement
oui c'est très important en fait le on a
un peu de mal à comprendre en fait ce
qui se passe avec le ségur mais c'est
d'après nous en tout cas le collectif un
terreau pitot une mauvaise réponse
finalement à des bonnes questions
la question de la revalorisation des
salaires vous l'avez très bien dit les
revendications il existe depuis
maintenant plus d'un an pour donner des
moyens à l'hôpital public pour paraître
simplement de pouvoir bien soigner les
patients le seul objectif de ces
revendications des collectifs c'est de
pouvoir faire correctement notre métier
ça fait plus d'un an et demi qu enfin
plus d'un an qu'on le dit ça fait des
années qu'on dénonce le les plans
d'austérité
et là on ne comprend pas comment il faut
encore aller dans la rue pour être
entendus et que on est enfin accès à ces
revendications qui sont très simples qui
doivent être urgente le ségur nord
aurait dû répondre d'emblée puisque tout
le monde était d'accord sur la question
de la revalorisation des salaires
donc ça c'est une urgence absolue parce
que sans revalorisation des salaires
sans revalorisation des carrières comme
vous l'avez très bien mentionné
finalement nous ne pourrons pas à garder
du personnel soignant dans les hôpitaux
publics
on ne pourra pas continuer à faire à
prodiguer des soins de qualité et en
toute sécurité
donc c'est vraiment une mesure urgente
c'était consensuel on ne comprend pas
pourquoi ça n'a pas été annoncé dès le
début il n'y a pas besoin de trois
semaines trois pas besoin de six
semaines
et puis pour tout le reste des mesures
qui sont hyper importante qui sont
notamment une réflexion autour de
l'organisation de l'hôpital delà de la
gouvernance c'est-à-dire de le savoir un
peu comment est-ce qu'on peut mieux
alors on va démocratiser d'une certaine
façon là les décisions dans nos
institutions hospitalières
ça c'est sûrement pas non plus en six
semaines qu'on arrivera à voir document
correct donc c'est ça peut être une
première étape pour des états généraux
de la santé
mais en tout cas le ségur ne répond à ni
à l'urgence ni aux problèmes de fond de
l'hôpital donc c'est vrai que c'est un
peu problématique et en attendant le
gouvernement on vient d'en parler
prévoit une prime convient de 19 ans
1500 euros mais ça ne va pas ça ne
concerne pas tout le monde
qu'en pensez vous oui ben je trouve que
vous avez votre reportage juste juste
avant l'intervention était très bien
fait c'est exactement ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que c'est une loterie s'est
laissée au choix du directeur ce qui est
évidemment très injuste il ya vraiment
une forme d'arbitraire de distribution
de cette cette prime qui est très
discutable
et puis surtout ça ne répond pas et vous
l'avez dit aussi ça ne répond pas aux
demandes du personnel et des besoins de
l'hôpital
on a à des primes dont on a besoin c'est
une vraie revalorisation des salaires
les plus bas
on ne demande pas pour me médecin je le
rappelle on se mobilise depuis plus d'un
an n'est pas pour les spas pour la
revalorisation du salaire des médecins
parce qu'on peut vivre avec nos salaires
mais par contre les plus bas salaires de
l'hôpital ça devient vraiment
extrêmement difficile pour tout le monde
dans toutes les régions et pour tous les
personnels et puis il ya des personnels
qui sont beaucoup mieux payés en libéral
ou en privé et donc les kinés lémanique
radio tout le monde même les instances
sociales femmes ont tout le monde peut
avoir des salaires meilleure qu'à
l'hôpital public alors qu c'est là qu'on
fait les meilleurs soins encore en
france donc si on veut préserver ce bien
commun il faut absolument qu'on est des
bonnes réponses et ses prix ne sont
vraiment pas une bonne réponse et moi je
pense que voilà effectivement là
actuellement le côté arbitraire de la
distribution de ces primes est
extrêmement problématique
je sais que c'est difficile de donner
des chiffres mais pour que ce
gouvernement vous donne un bon signal en
juillet la réponse que vous attendez si
vous deviez donner un chiffre en termes
de revalorisations des salaires
on a demandé à une revalorisation des
salaires de tous les bas salaires de
l'hôpital avec que qu'ils puissent
rejoindre la moyenne de l'oscd alors
c'est pas inconnu pour tous les salaires
mais c'est au minimum
en tout cas une revalorisation de 300
euros donc c'est pas grand-chose 300
euros là quand on paye des heures
supplémentaires quand on paye des gens
en intérim ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
aux hôpitaux beaucoup plus chers à
l'ensemble des citoyens français sur
leurs impôts parce que finalement si on
le paye tous
donc il ya il faut qu'on ait un vrai un
vrai à une vraie stratégie
d'attractivité et il faut cette
revalorisation au minimum de 300 euros
et ça peut être plus parce que si on
veut rejoindre vraiment la moyenne des
pays de l'ocde notamment pour les
infirmières en réalité ça représente
plus
donc c'est vraiment un minimum et pour
l'instant on n'a aucun signal on a non
plus aucune annonce chiffrée de grands
plans massifs comme l'a annoncé le
président de la république le 20 mars
il a promis un plan massif pour
l'hôpital public il ya eu des mesures
chiffrées pour le peintre entreprises
aéronautiques pour d'autres entreprises
ça rien n'a été ou jean-louis annoncé
par l'hôpital public ça reste assez
surréaliste il ya deux nouvelles
journées d'action on en a entendu parler
hier le 30 juin et le 14 juillet vous
serez présente vous allez participer ces
journées d'action oui bah on va en
discuter effectivement je pense que là
on est on espère qu'on aura des réponses
avant je sais si le scission si le
gouvernement n'entend toujours pas
l'urgence de la situation on ne n'est
pas la fin je ne sais pas des
revendications qui sont catégorielles
qui sont là la seule urgence c'est
sauver l'hôpital public en france donc
il faut absolument qu'on ait les moyens
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir continuer à
fonctionner garde un hôpital public
debout
c'est urgent et on espère que ça pourra
même être être annoncé demain
merci beaucoup à vous se fit creuser
d'avoir répondu en direct à vos
questions je rappelle que cette
neurologue à la pitié salpêtrière
membres du collectif inter à hôpitaux